on va tout de suite partir à mikolif
dans le sud du pays retrouvé Karim
Yahyaoui l'un de nos envoyer spéciaux en
Ukraine Karim bonsoir vous vous êtes
rendu sur la ligne de front les lignes
aujourd'hui elles bougent peu le groupe
paramilitaire Wagner Wagner qui combat
au côté de l'armée russe à annoncé tout
à l'heure la prise d'un village près de
barmut à barmut c'est là où se concentre
en ce moment les combats
c'est vrai que les lignes bougent peu
c'est vrai qu'il y a essentiellement un
affrontement avec l'artillerie c'est
l'essentiel de cette guerre finalement
depuis plusieurs mois du côté de Wagner
on utilise énormément d'hommes pour
tenter de prendre un certain nombre de
localités autour de bar mouth et c'est
ce que nous ont raconté des artilleurs
Ukrainiens ils expliquaient que des
vagues d'hommes sont envoyés à la mort
mais pour tenter justement de faire
basculer l'avantage du côté des Russes
il tente donc de prendre l'avantage de
cette manière mais c'est vrai que les
choses sont assez figées avec deux
artillerie qui s'affrontent et des deux
côtés on a beaucoup de mal à prendre
l'avantage alors du côté de Bart mot les
hommes devenus Prigogine semblent
avancer peu à peu mais même pour eux
c'est extrêmement difficile d'ailleurs
il a reconnu lui-même que il y aurait
peut-être une prise de batmouth mais pas
avant mars ou avril et c'est vrai qu'il
avait en quelque sorte laisser entendre
que barkout pourrait être prise le 24 ou
au moins pour le 24 février en guise de
cadeaux pour Vladimir Poutine ce n'est
pas ce qui s'est produit et les choses
évoluent peu sur ce front du côté de
donuts notamment où nous nous sommes
rendus mais aussi du côté de Harrison
cette ville qui se trouve sur la ligne
de front ou les choses évoluent là aussi
assez peu mais entre ces deux artillies
qui s'affrontent il y a des populations
qui chaque jour risque leur vie il y a
régulièrement des victimes à cause des
tirs russes qui s'abattent sur halson
mais aussi sur toute la région de Herson
loblast de halson où les jeux les gens
tentent de reprendre peu à peu une vie
normale mais c'est très difficile dans
les villages qui entourent callson et
encore plus dans cette ville merci